Chevrolet equinox two thousand and
owner's opinion with positive and negative points.
the first positive point
the engine,
he has two hundred and seventy-two horses
and has an excellent performance.
second
has excellent suspension,
he filters a lot the regularity of São Paulo,
at least the puffed lights we have here.
third the car has a lot of technology
and excellent sound quality.
room I also really liked the stability
four-wheel drive,
right?
there's no way.
fifth engine and generator reliability.
sixth the floor in the back row is flat,
unlike the tigan which has a slightly high tunnel.
now i will talk about the negative point.
first
there are many people who complain
that she doesn't have seven seats.
second gear change is only on one button
on the lever of the knee,
It's pretty bad to switch gears there,
huh.
third part of consumption
people have no like the engine.
two zero points
turbo with two hundred and sixty-two horses,
whether the car makes ten or seven or eight,
I don't know,
it's not going to do in São Paulo.
mine makes five and a half six
in well-loaded traffic
on the road he passes ten.
room has no way to disable the top status on the panel,
but it has a Brazilian way,
go to the free market,
egg in the whip and installs it in the car and everything is resolved
no panel error.
fifth front of car scrapes quite easily
in ditches.
sixth o.
car stresses very little,
need to more times.
and if you liked that content,
like and subscribe.
until the next video!